el desempleo no da tregua en la región
de américa latina es nuestro tema de
inicio aquí en economía está conmigo en
el estudio daniel hablando con daniela
muy buenas noches preocupante estas
cifras de la región de américa latina en
cuanto al desempleo claro que si
santiago y vamos a hablar
específicamente de dos países de la
región que revelaron este jueves sus
cifras más recientes con cortes al
primer trimestre y abril
hablamos de méxico y brasil- en este
último la desocupación del 14,7 por
ciento en el trimestre es la más alta
desde que iniciaron los nuevos registros
en 2012 e implica que el 14,8 millones
de personas no tienen empleo la
diferencia es de más de 2 millones
frente a lo que teníamos hace un año en
mexico por su parte la tasa de desempleo
trimestral fue del 4,4 por ciento un
punto más que el año pasado y en abril
fue mayor del 4,7 por ciento lo que en
términos absolutos santiago significa
2,7 millones de personas sin trabajo ya
propósito del tema laboral en la región
argentina decidió prorrogar por un mes
la prohibición de los despidos
en causa justificada una medida que está
vigente desde marzo del año pasado
daniela que lo que está pasando en chile
que los trabajadores de una de las
operaciones de bhp en ese país
suramericano entraron en huelga pues
santiago el gigante minero
anglo-australiano bhp billiton opera
junto con una empresa australiana y un
consorcio japonés la mina escondida que
es el yacimiento de cobre más productivo
del mundo ubicado en el desierto de
atacama pues su sindicato el local
comenzó una huelga indefinida después de
que fracasaran negociaciones laborales
pero el cese de actividad de santiago no
será propiamente en la mina sino a 1300
kilómetros en su centro de operaciones
remoto que queda en santiago pero los
200 trabajadores que están ahí son
indispensables porque desde allí
controlan los procesos productivos como
extracción compras ventas despachos
entre otros la empresa dice que va a
reemplazar a estos empleados en un plan
de contingencia para no afectar la
operación recordemos que chile es el
mayor productor
de cobre metal que por estos días está
cotizando en máximos históricos y usted
no se ha reportado acá en economía en
france 24 hablemos ahora de la ocde o la
osce de que pidió corregir esas fallas
estructurales que presentan los países
en américa latina con este jueves tuvo
lugar el foro internacional sobre
latinoamérica y el caribe que
normalmente se celebra en parís y que
por segundo año consecutivo se organizó
en línea por culpa de la pandemia en el
ángel gurría a quien le quedan pocos
días como secretario general del
organismo recordó que américa latina dio
un retroceso promedio del 77 en su
producto interno bruto en 2020 y dijo
que los problemas de la región no son
sólo culpa de la pandemia escuchémoslo
por si fuera poco la pandemia volvió a
la región cuando ésta enfrentaba lo que
llamamos las cuatro trampas del
desarrollo la baja productividad la
vulnerabilidad social
la debilidad institucional y la
insostenibilidad ambiental hablemos
ahora de la república islámica de irán
que previó las cripto monedas por su
alto consumo de energía quien no
pensaría como le parece pues mire la
medida anunciada por el presidente asan
rohan y estará vigente durante casi
cuatro meses hasta el 22 de septiembre y
fue tomada debido a los constantes
apagones que ha sufrido el país de los
que el gobierno culpa a la gran cantidad
de energía que requieren las cripto
monedas coincidencia o no lo hace justo
cuando se acercan las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo mes mire yo
lo explico santiago bitcoin y otras
cripto divisas funcionan a través de un
proceso conocido como minería en el que
poderosos computadores compiten entre sí
para resolver complejas operaciones
matemáticas y consume mucha electricidad
datos de la universidad de cambridge
dicen que el consumo mundial anual de
energía de las cripto monedas es más
alto que toda la demanda de países como
filipinas o países bajos hablemos ahora
de indicadores wall street' tercero
mixto
de conocerse que las peticiones de ayuda
por desempleo volvieron a caer las
acciones europeas cerraron mixtas
algunas impulsadas por eeuu y poner paz
porque el gigante aeronáutico mejoró sus
proyecciones de producción y los
mercados latinoamericanos avanzaron en
sao paulo estuvo a punto de romper
récord histórico cifra el de aparecer
385 soles es el valor histórico del que
se cotizó hoy el dólar en perú tras
subir por cuarta jornada consecutiva en
medio de la incertidumbre electoral es
el precio más alto de la divisa
estadounidense en el país y en
consecuencia el más bajo que ha tenido
la moneda local muchas gracias daniela
por esta actualización del mundo
económico es todo por el momento aquí en
france 24